starting the next half we're running a
big Banks because it's uh we will aim to
finish the stock at 1105
and then instructions
2015 we'll start at 7 30. so we'll break
for lunch at 125
all right so guys will kind of put here
okay so uh so we talked about what
happens in one round now what happens in
multiple rounds I'm gonna get that a bit
quickly uh the idea is now what you can
do is you can have a lower bound that
looks like n over one so here notice we
have the rounds as well as a parameter
right so this is p raised to 1 over this
is the diameter of the query the
diameter is if you think about your
query as a graph it's just the diameter
of the graph
and then this is
divided by two and we can actually have
an algorithm that matches within within
one round so I think an example here
it's easier to understand what's
happening is take the path query right
so here we just have a path and let's
say we want the Computing in what our
rounds then we need this much load okay
so here and here diameter is K so you
need K of one over R by 2 and the idea
here is that essentially you
your number of rounds depends
logarithmically on your diameter right
so here if you have one round you have
to use hypercube you get n by between
fourth with two rounds you can do better
with three rounds your sensory already
at optimal right so you do n by P so any
more rounds will not help you to
decrease the load so here I think this
is an interesting example because here
you can see a clear trade-off between
the rounds you're using and the load
you're getting the more rounds I have
the kind of more uh less load uh I can
do
um now one interesting result of that is
on so this does not consider output at
all but the longer you get when you get
more because in these outputs yeah so
this works only for matching databases
it doesn't work
so for this algorithm the lower bound is
fine to work for matching databases but
for your upper bound you also you only
need multi databases for this to work
it's like you have yeah essentially when
you join your intermediate Size Doesn't
increase at all that's one the way to
think about this
um
okay so here is an interesting corollary
of that so let's say we want to do
something like Transit closure
uh then this tells us that if you want
to get any load that is strictly less
than n
you actually the non-constant number of
rounds okay
and why the idea is that it's
essentially here transitive closure is
nothing more than a path that K grows uh
to be as big as kind of the diameter of
your graph okay
so so we can get this mount
any questions
I won't have more time to go over this
bus
okay great
okay uh now let's talk about skew and
actually the the what I'm going to
briefly talk about now and see how is
going to be about skew uh do you want to
talk about this or
okay okay
uh so
how do we think about skew
so let's suppose we want to join two
relations of size n okay so this is just
your join but now we don't need
intersection
so what is hyperloop going to do well uh
it's basically going to give all the
shares to Y this is going to correspond
to doing a hash join okay so uh in order
where if you decide we're going to send
this Double R go to Hassan Y and we're
going to set the topic from is you're
just going to ask on why you're gonna
you're gonna ignore completely x and z
okay
so now this is the case so here what
I've plotted is the values of Y and the
frequency of R this by frequency I mean
how many times does this value appear in
the top linear okay
so
if we are under some Fresco so now
what's going to happen is that when we
has
you can think about all the tuples that
share the same y will end up in the same
machine okay
so uh if we has this these are pretty
small so you can argue with this
actually formal argument about this this
will be one of the exercises uh you can
argue that this will be kind of
uniformly distributed as you would
expect so the load will be r divided by
P but now what happens if you have
something like this well then all of
these values because you're casting only
on y needs to go in will go in one
Machine by the construction of your
house function which means you're going
to have something like this and now your
calculation is not correct so you're not
going to get that your load is going to
be R by P it's just going to be
something that's much bigger than that
okay in the worst case you're going to
have
one value that contains everything and
then your load no matter how good your
function is going to be it's going to be
r instead of R by P right and then
that's a disaster
so
um
how do we deal with that uh well we now
think about worst case optimality so now
we want to design algorithms such that
we
we want it to work with the worst case
input okay so we want to have an
algorithm so that it's load matches the
worst case instance uh that satisfies
and giving statistics in our case we're
going to talk about size of our inputs
and output size as well
all right
okay
so sorry I have to escape all those guys
okay when data skill exists you'll have
to pay a higher load complexity okay
let's uh take out the triangle joint uh
when there's no data skill uh we have a
single round algorithm with such a load
complexity but when data skill exists
what we can the best that we can do is
just a a algorithm with a load and
overall P
um
but if we are allowed with one more
round of computation we can further
decrease the load due to this again okay
but this exponent is related to the
fractional Edge covering number okay so
what we can do with just the two rounds
okay suppose there's a heavy heater in
the attribute of the X then it's
degenerates to compute this residual
joint query if we are only allowed with
a single round we have to compute the
Cartesian product between I and the T
and in the worst case their size can be
as the largest and so we have to pay a
load of n over rupee but if we are
allowed with two rounds the magic thing
we can do is simply semi Joy okay we can
do the semi joint between S and R in the
first round and the semi joint between
s19 using another round okay
and compared to the calcium project the
stem joins much more uh it's cheaper
okay so that's why we can decrease the
load
I think um
again uh second pulling okay I'm sorry
that this is the fractional Edge cozy
packing yeah
uh the algorithm oh okay
okay
this is the algorithm
okay yeah
the hell of idea is that we can see that
the heavy heater in every subset of
attributes and then use the skill free
uh algorithm have a cube algorithm to
compute the residual joint card yeah so
since that you have different you
partition your data according to your
heavy heaters and then you design a
different hyper tube algorithm
with different shares for these
partitions you can can you show us the
slide again
oh yeah
the very the triangle triangle okay
can you come continue click one more
good so the second the second bullet
says that if uh the value of x is heavy
then you just ignore it uh
the query at the bottom yes uh which you
compute using a different algorithm
exactly yeah can you explain the same
way the second the two round excuse what
you will do there uh the two rounds is
that actually we have a threshold for
the data for the heavy heater and for
each heavy heater we will allocate some
servers and then for each heavy heater
we just do this uh semi-joint stuff yeah
and how does your load decrease from
um one by three to the one half to the
one by T to the two skirts okay we can
see that the uh the threshold will be
over uh P to the juicers and there are
uh I think it's one third one so there
are P to the power of one third heavy
heaters uh in total and for each have a
heater we just allocate the P to the
power of two thirds servers then we just
get a linear node for this one we will
achieve such a low yeah
I think that the way to think about this
that this residual query if you have one
round you have to pay more computer than
having two rounds
that's the real reason
because you can do the same job you can
get an end by B basically but the the if
you do one round then you have to do the
Cartesian program
so one more round gives you more more
things
[Music]
match the what is complexity for
trundles for say around equal to one and
process is equal to one or
uh yes when the load going to when the
the P the number of servers just you can
imagine as the running time you are not
completing the time we don't care about
the time we just care about the the load
yeah yeah the number of tacos received
okay
so uh if there's a single heavy heater
here then this query can simply done
with an overp yeah but there could be
multiple heavy heaters then we need to
allocate the servers to each heavy
feature and then handle them separately
okay
I I don't think the two round is clear
but in U.S two rounds
two rounds because you need first round
to materialize their semi joint result
they'll say the same general result is S
Prime then you'll need another round to
do same join between ice Prime and T
okay and that it will be uh linear like
n by B
they said you have you need to repeat
this for every wine you do this in
parallel and that is where for every X
for every heavy X yeah
so okay I will give you a big picture
about the worst case optimal algorithm
in multiple rounds or I measure multiple
runs we still stick to count number runs
but the constant can depends on the size
of the query for example the number of
relations or number of attributes uh in
the sequential model we have a nice
worst case optimal algorithm and also we
can use the counting argument to get
such a lower bound okay
and algorithm with such load complexity
has been achieved for you know some path
query don't miss a way to join click
join and later to graph join and very
recently to a cyclic joints
at the same time we observe a higher
lower bound okay for some cyclic joint
and this is related to the edge packing
number so this observation also rules
out the possibility possibility of
achieving a unified uh load complexity
for the worst case optimal joint
algorithm and the big open question is
what query dependent quantity or
quantities can capture the harness of
worst case optimal joint algorithm in
the FCC model uh and in today's talk I
will only cover the worst case optimal
algorithm for acyclic joints okay let me
quickly go through this slides the high
level idea is that besides harshing we
need some other powerful Primitives such
as sorting prefix sum and the
multi-search to build our mpcr Rhythm
and all those Primitives can be done
very efficiently in NPC mode in NPC
model
um okay I will skip this
um for example using semi joins we can
remove dangling couples for cyclic joint
we can also reduce the join by by
removing relations whose attributes are
completely contained in another one and
we can also use the reduced by key to
compute the degree information or the
frequency okay
now uh let's go into the acyclic joints
uh a joint queries obviously click if
there is a joint Trace such that there's
a one-to-one correspondence between the
relations in the joint query and the no
Symmetry and also for every attribute
the set of nodes containing this
attribute former collected subtree
um so the young cakes algorithm is
already output optimal it performs the
bottom up semi joint and the top down
semi joint so all the dangling tuples
will be removed
um then we can just do a any pairwise
joint ordering according the tree
according to the Joint trade the number
of intermediate join results can always
bounded by the final join result so this
is optimal
but this idea does not work in a PC
model at least it does not give us very
efficient algorithm in NPC the challenge
is that we have to shuffle a large
number of intermediate join results
okay and those intermediate results will
serve as the input relation for the
subsequent joint operator so it's very
costly in the NPC model each server can
just image the join result from its
local memory for free without any
suffering so there is no way to bound
such a term in the MPC model okay
we need some other important structure
of the joint tree
which is the canonical Edge cover
okay foreign the optimal fractional Edge
covering may not be unique uh some of
them are of particular importance to us
and we just identify them as canonical
um okay I will give a procedure to
define the clinical Edge cover
first for node and the attribute we call
this attribute as the disappearing
attribute for this node if this node is
the highest one industry containing this
attribute okay intuitively this
attribute will disappear once you leave
the substrate rooted at this node okay
for example the for attribute C uh ABC
bcuc J and CF so there's no for this
node this is a disappearing actual learn
how to find the colonical edge cover
okay we start with the joint tree and
with the empathy Edge cover initially we
always peel off a leaf node
if there is a disappearing attribute not
covered yet
we add this node to the edge cover
otherwise we just discard this okay we
will repeat this procedure until the
jointry becomes empty okay let me show a
random example we start with the sniffle
Bo always The Disappearing attribute so
we add it to the edge cover we move to
ABC
is the disappearing attribute we added
move to BD this disappearing attribute
we also added
we will continue
okay
until we find the current Concordia
cover
they are very nice properties about the
edge cover we just found
um the first thing is that no matter how
you choose the uh they flow through peel
off you will always get the same
canonical Edge cover and more important
thing is that this canonical Edge cover
is optimal means that the number of
relations chosen by the edge cover is
exactly row star it's exactly the
fraction of edge covering number
okay
this is a small exercise for you to show
the optimality okay
the natural question is how does the
canonical Edge cover lead to a worst
case optimal algorithm
this straightforward in the sequential
Ram model because you can just compute
the Cartesian product of those relations
in a clinical Edge cover SQ Prime and
then filter The Joint result in Q Prime
with the remaining relations okay the
running time is always bounded by the
size of Q Prime so this is the worst
case optimal
with a similar reason
this is not efficient in the NPC model
because we have to shuffle in Q Prime
this is very very costly
recall that our Target of the worst case
optimal algorithm is simply n over P to
the one over row star so you can see the
Gap here
the question is what we can do with such
a load complexity
it seems that we can we are only
affordable to compute the Cartesian
product of at most row star relations
yeah
everything when you talk about the
Cartesian product of relations to the
sequential algorithm since the nodes
they share attributes is it unique
pathogen products you can just do a
custom product and then filter
check whether they have the same value
on the common attribute
you can just compute their catching
product you can just treat them as
different attribute first just compute
their calcium product and check whether
this is a valid joint result by checking
the joint condition and this is not
this is not less efficient than doing a
job like if everything is
a drink yes but
it's your worst case optimal if you just
only care about the running into the
power row star time complexity we are
doing a CP quiz here so roster is
yeah we don't need you don't need to do
complicated stuff
yeah but I mean you get the impression
that if you have like a some attribute
like Angel green many times you can see
the old combinations of age and only
afterwards you those are the ones where
it's the same value everywhere aren't
you using time
yeah but if you only care about worst
case optimality this is
this is already a worst case of demand I
thought it was always the same right
yeah
the worst case instances we have only
one value for each other okay
Okay so
the question is which row star relations
are we affordable to compute
it must have something to do with the
canonical Edge cover and I hope you will
find the answer after I present the
algorithm okay uh algorithm is a little
bit complicated but I will try to
simplify it okay as much as possible so
we start with the internal node is zero
in the canonical Edge cover whose
descendants in the canonical Edge cover
are all leaves in this tree
for example ehj is such a internal node
we want you we want to do but HK is not
a valid one because uh this is
descendant in the canonical Edge cover
is not at least okay
now we find the attribute X and The
Descendant lymph node e y in the
clinical Edge cover such that this
attribute appears in every node on the
path from E1 to e0
okay this is always doable and you can
you can try okay try to prove yeah the
unshaded nodes are not
his cover exactly your drug pass through
them so I don't understand how you're
doing that uh
I mean as of
anything this uh in The Descendant means
in a joint way
jointry if this joint treatment is given
joint yeah
yeah can come from uh just give an
arbitrary joint
before this joint
thank you
then we are just joining heavy light
decomposition okay this is a common
Technique we will use now we can see the
the values in attribute c as heavy if it
is degrading any relation on this path
is greater than l
and the light otherwise
for every after we fix a constant in the
attribute C okay okay let me just
skip this one okay uh you can see that c
e j can be reduced by this ehj because
now you can play a semi join so we just
remove it and the move is two children
upward as the new children of the ehj
okay you will see that CJ can also can
also be reduced by EFG so we just try to
reduce the joint tree using semi joints
okay they will just do a semi joint and
moved ehg EFG upward as the new children
of ehg then we just revoke the whole
algorithm recursively and you can still
check that this is still a valid
colonical Edge cover for this one okay
for the lighter values okay we're just
using packing we put that values into
groups such that the total degree of
each group is roughly l in all the
relations on this path
as this input for each specific group
okay
we observe that those input tuples are
very small because they are the most L
tables in those relations so we can just
broadcast them to all the servers okay
allocated for this group okay
and then we will left with a bunch of
this collection subtree we will handle
them separately and then join their
result by the calcium product
okay I will not go into the details but
I will show some high level idea about
why this algorithm is worst case optimal
uh to show the analysis we need a notion
of a path cover okay based on the
canonical Edge cover this is essentially
how our algorithm chooses the path okay
for example uh the past cover
intuitively use a set of path to cover
the nodes in in the drawing tree and
those paths know the disjoint and each
path each path just contains one node in
a colonical edge cover so in this
smaller geometry for example we can use
a b c b c e c js1 path okay and then we
use EFG to cover these two nodes and in
the for the remaining nodes each of them
will form a individual path okay
um as each path only contains exactly
one node in a clinical Edge cover so the
number of paths in a pass cover is
exactly row star okay
then the load of our algorithm is
essentially Computing the Cartesian
product of a subside of relations
this substance is not arbitrary it does
not contain two relations from the same
path in the past cover
in this way we can found the size of
such subside relations by raw star and
we just relate the load complexity of
this algorithm to This n over P to the
power
so back to my previous question
we are affordable to compute the calcium
product of raw star relations but each
relation should come from a distinct
path in the past cover
okay
so yep the heavy light analysis assumed
to be free is it done dynamically
because in the distributed setting I
don't understand how that doesn't cost
more communication or something
uh heavy lights yes
yeah exactly we need some count by key
or reduced package you collect those
information first and that's just a
thousand numbers it's a linear but it's
uh linear load yeah
yeah that's why you need to pay to pay
more to pay one round more for I mean
yeah what is the number of rounds
because you need to do searching sorting
at least the accounts number for the
reduced by key before the algorithm the
whole algorithm is constant and constant
depends on number of attributes yeah
yeah that makes sense
so I have just over here and the quickly
go over the lower bound so the high
level idea is that for this simple
drawing query it has uh
row Star as a tube but a fraction Edge
covering as two by fractional packing
number three uh previously we believe
this is the correct Target and but this
is the best that we can do so there's a
gap between a lower bound and upper
bound and data show that okay indeed
there exists a higher lower bound uh a
big open question is uh what's current
dependent quantity can capture the worst
case optimal algorithm and we conject it
conjecture that they should be related
to the max between the fractional Edge
recovery and the packing number of the
reducer joint but it's still open so we
need both upper bound and the lower
bounds to answer this question okay
oh sorry I don't have more time to go
through the approve but okay I will just
uh give this one
um I think I will use the remaining 10
minutes to Shell another exciting
algorithm with you okay
uh once we get the worst case open
algorithm we we move to the output
sensible output optimal algorithm
um this algorithm for the two table
drawings quite
um quite straightforward it can be
viewed as the MPC version of the sort of
merge join algorithm so we sort the
couples by their drawing value and for
join value if all the tuples fall inside
one server we can let the server to
compute the join result locally and for
the joint for the remaining joint values
okay they are potentially the heavy
heater we need to allocator service
proportional to the input size for the
specific drawing value as well as the
output size for this joint value and
then we just run how to cube algorithm
to compute all the calcium products in
parallel
okay I will skip the analysis but just
to mention the beautiful results uh it's
n over P plus root out over p and this
root out of p is also optimal by a
similar counting argument because each
server receiving out apples can produce
Atmos the elsewhere join results we must
have P times L Square greater than out
okay
lower bound on the load complexity
so I will move to the output sensitive
algorithm for executive Joy there's some
interesting observation there
um in a sequential model the parallel uh
pairwise uh framework okay already give
us output optimal algorithm uh this
pairwise framework can also be generated
to the NPC version but this outputs
dependent term is very expensive uh it's
not optimal even for the two table
drawing we just get a better low count
plastic here you can see the quadratic
difference here and this result can be
extended to a larger class
of joint course named R heracle joint
okay
um okay I will skip this one the High
Life idea is that we our hierarchical
joint is a simple combination between
reduce the joint and hierarchical joy
okay so there's a separation between our
hierarchical joint and then our
hierarchical joint okay so this is
always achievable for our hierarchical
joint but we will prove some higher
lower Bound for our hydroxide
the interesting part I want to share
okay in the meantime is the hybrid
strategy of the parallel parallel
pairwise framework
okay for a second drawing we can get an
algorithm with such a load complexity
this is also the first Improvement
strict improvement over the parallel
young caucus algorithm so
first the optimality is not very
satisfactory because it's still limits
to very small output size okay I also
learned from house talking about camp
that they also use the hybrid strategy
over the ghds but for us for cyclic
joints but here for a sticky join we
already need the power of hybrid
strategy in our PC mode so sure I'm
confused here because the um the upper
the upper Bank in general yeah
related to raw star somehow
that is the worst case optimal worst
case
back here we use we we have some other
parameters out
right but even without you
still need I mean you can you can
express a lower bound based on out and
throw star exactly
why wouldn't we think about Rockstar
here is Rockstar fixed in this
hierarchical query so okay just for this
case when the output size
uh for example when the output size is
uh greater than P times n we already
know that the worst case optimal
algorithm is the best that we can do
which there's no hope for output
sensitive algorithm
yeah so
it doesn't mean only in the worst case
we have the low star uh
is the is the tight lower bound what is
for example the lines Rejoice are
hierarchical Joy so the Rose Dies two
yeah can you show the diagram you have I
think that's very useful uh problem size
yeah that's for the line three
um okay maybe I can finish this part and
then show the diagram for the lines
rejoin so maybe I can give some comments
after you hear the parallel uh hybrid
the pairwise framework okay
um let's just move one step forward from
the two table joint to a three table
joint and there are two possible joint
orderings here uh the idea is quite
simple the question is which joint
ordering is the best okay uh for example
on this joint instance uh we know that
the first joint ordering joint R1 R2
first will give you a very large
intermediate result so this is not good
uh
as the as the second one but if we just
have a symmetric instance there's a
second joint ordering will beat the
first one uh sorry the first one will be
to the second one because it has a much
smaller intermediate join result but if
we just put them together so either
pairwise ordering have two shuffling so
many intermediate results
um this also gives us the insights of
the algorithm
we can decompose The Joint into multiple
pieces and then find the good joint
ordering for each piece so this is how
hybrid okay how
and our three table join there is quite
a simple way to decompose The Joint
instance we just decompose the join okay
by the value B in attribute uh uh for it
depends on the degree in relation R1 so
for the
heavy values which compute r2r3 first
and for Q2 for the light values we just
compute R1 R2 first okay so we can mount
their intermediate result in this way
because each partial intermediate result
will join at least the Teletubbies in
the final drawing result so this is at
most Auto virtual and for this one they
are at the most enterpose in R2 and each
of them can be joined with at most uh
Tau tapos okay by the definition of
light values okay and we just set the
value of Tau to balance these two terms
then get such a
load complexity
okay okay
I think in the last
part I want to show is uh recursive
strategy to decompose the acyclic join
okay
we always pick okay we all speak an
internal node whose children are all
leaves okay
so we handle the heavy values in each
Leaf load
separately so the heaviest depend is
defined on the degree of this joint
value in this relation uh strategy is
simple we just sorry oh it's no
animation there okay we just joined the
remaining relation as a single relation
and then reduce it to a binary join okay
for this one we join this remaining
relation as well oh this cup so sorry I
look for the last one yeah we also
joined the remaining relation and it
reduced to a binary drawing
and then we handle heavy values in their
internal node but here the heavy
analyzed definition is defined on the
sub join not in this uh internal node
okay similarly we just decompose The
Joint tree at this node and materialize
each subtree separately and then reduced
to uh our hierarchical join
as last we handle all the light values
in the internal node and leaf load we
materialize this sub tree as a single
relation and run the whole algorithm
recursively so the key idea is that the
size of intermediate Joy results
generated is always bounded by root n
times out so we can get such a low
complex
sorry I think this is a little bit uh
downstairs but the last picture I want
to show is
the lines rejoined the simple is the
none are none are hierarchical joint
uh we have a full understanding of the
output optimality for the line three
drawing when output size is small
is optimal
when Apple size is sufficiently large
but not as large as the worst case for
example it's larger than n times P the
worst case optimal algorithm is the best
that we can do but when Apple size 4
inside this range
we need the output sensitive algorithm I
just described and this is also optimal
so you can say the output optimal for
line three joint and PCs such a form
okay but we don't know for General now
our hierarchical joy we will when we
have one more relation with R4 d e
we don't have a full understanding of
the output optimal
so we need more
algorithms here yeah to understand the
whole picture
okay I think I I will have to stop here
but yeah I have to see the many
interesting results for the sparse
matrix multiplication so if you are
interested I'm happy to talk offline
yeah
so that's the picture is that
name yeah exactly the main result yeah
so this is the sparse Matrix
modification we we already showed output
optimality and similarly when the output
size is small we can do just aggregate
in a car case when the Apple size is
large here we have the threshold and
greater than Ruby then the worst case
optimal algorithm is is the best okay
when the output size just fall between
the syringe we have some output
sensitive algorithm to do that
so this is another level of hybrid
strategy yeah
we get a resultant
zero entries in the yeah exactly it
could be much smaller than the full join
result yeah and this thing in the middle
is also optimal for this query yeah
Optimum yeah
yeah so this is the Waterway known from
aggregate the young attackers yeah
okay so yeah thank you yeah I will stop
here and happy to talk with you in
afternoon
[Applause]
can we get back
[Music]